[Music]
pink towers and giant dragons sounds
like a scene from a fairy tale but in
this case it's not in the Sam Braun
district sits one of Thailand's most
unique temples what Sam Braun is a pink
shrine dedicated to the Buddhist faith
and measures 260 feet or 80 metres high
representing the age of Buddha when he
died while the temple is known for the
giant encircling dragon its meaning
remains a mystery Bhuvana Bhutto the
founder of the temple was inspired to
create the hollow dragon building during
a seven-day fasting meditation
construction took only five years
visitors can climb the stairs of the
17-story temple to touch the dragon's
beard
or they can climb inside the belly of
the beast this temple is a must visit
for people looking to discover something
truly one-of-a-kind
[Music]
in London Ontario there lives a man
whose basement is unlike anything you've
ever seen this is Robert ward off hi my
name is Robert ward Oh Robert has been
playing the same Dungeons & Dragons
campaign for over 30 years 35 years to
be exact I'm sorry that's okay
welcome would you like to play a Worman
robe you look like a rogue wait let's
back up for a second Dungeons & Dragons
is a fantasy role-playing game or a
group of people come together and play
on adventures dictated by Dungeon Master
these adventures also known as campaigns
are set in the Dungeons & Dragons world
and normally have an end point or they
just fizzle out due to people's lack of
commitment but Robert is in a league of
his own and here's why the dude has a
serious collection
I think our collection of miniatures is
around 20,000 and then over the years I
discovered terrain ultimately I'm a
collector also and a lot of my enjoyment
comes from being able to get new stuff
and to put new stuff on the table so the
players are constantly coming across new
settings because it's a game that
doesn't stick to one particular campaign
setting I'm able to use any things that
actually fit the world and so it is a
long process but over thirty five years
you can develop a credit collection as
Roberts collection grew so did the
number of players word began to spread
about the neverending campaign we have
people coming from all over the country
to play often flying in weight all over
the country that's right now these are
some of the people who play in Roberts
game where are you guys from
I flew in from Saskatoon Saskatchewan I
drove in from Toronto Brussels Ontario
mocha Ontario Calgary Alberta hold on
what happens if people can't fly in or
drive to Robert's house to play hey
everyone
problem solved
[Music]
the game has always been determined
really through friendship it's really
been a way that I keep my friends
together I knew early on that if I was
able to create a game that was good
enough and that means it had to be
better than video games it had to be
better than any other game they could
find that they would keep coming no
matter where I was and so that takes
again imagination and it takes change
and it takes having a system that is
constantly dynamic that is changing that
is growing and that is constantly
getting better
[Music]
hi i'm lenny lipton this is my dog bell
lenny lipton is sitting in his living
room Puff the Magic Dragon reading
something you've probably heard live by
the sea and frolicked in the autumn mist
in a land called honah Lee
Lenny wrote what has become the stoners
anthem
I wrote Puff the Magic Dragon when he
was a 19 year old college student I was
a freshman at Cornell
well can you sit thank you dear okay I
was reading a poem by Ogden Nash called
custard the dragon soon after he went to
meet friends for dinner and as I was
walking down the hill just to the
apartment I was thinking about the poem
I read and I thought I'd try to write
one too about a dragon he got to his
friend's apartment and let himself in I
saw a typewriter on a kitchen table I
type puff the magic dragon lived by the
sea and frolicked in the autumn mist the
line called on only and although I
didn't find out about this for a couple
of years peter Yarrow
who became the peter peter paul and mary
is one of the guys who lived in the
apartment he saved the poem I could
completely forgot about I even left it
in the typewriter and he set it to music
that's how the Sun opens and it changed
my life
[Music]
but Lenny's story doesn't stop there
I've got something like seventy two
patents invented the way to project 3d
movies you're likely to see if you go to
the cinemas he also invented those
awkward glasses you have to wear to see
them
this is crystallize this is the first
commercial pair of 3d active electronic
I work and everyone from NASA to James
Cameron his youth at NASA on Mars and
Cameron underwater Lenny is also a
filmmaker he's produced over 25 movies
it's a Lifetime Achievement Award and
he's written several books all about
well film and one autobiography
but I don't think it's of interest we've
read one chapter and she said she's
going to read it anymore okay so a book
about his life is not his magnum opus
good thing a song about drugs is because
that's what it's about right and people
want to think it's about pot that's fine
with me
wait it's not not as far as I'm
concerned Puff the Magic Dragon is not
about drugs and who knows who knows what
I was thinking dragon spear is a
tradition of pulling the hot mo into
fire tres that resembles step of the
dragon spear people have been making
dragon spear for thousands of years in
China it was the favorite delicacy of
the royalties many would say that we are
the only authentic dragon spear maker
here in Singapore
[Music]
and my name is Raja poon I've been
making dragon spirit candy with my
cousin auntie Lily for more than 30
years to me is a delicacy that can be
enjoyed almost every day before 1988
that would anyone making dragon spirit
readily available in Singapore
she is Singapore first dragon beard
candy lady it's a craft she passed on to
me and therefore I am able to continue
making this dragon be readily available
for one and all to save her here in
Singapore first we have to cook the pure
mod and ensure that it can harden into a
shape of a donut we have to use fresh
peanuts and then we have to crush it
into five bits of peanut crush from then
onwards we will continue using our
strength the pool and to pull and to
pull into the shape of a number eight
until the treads of mod become even
finer than any humans hair with this
fine trace of dragon spirit we'll wrap
it with the crushed peanut the dragon
spirit Candida is freshly made will be
soft and smooth when he enters your
mouth it will melt immediately
once I've mastered this craft I give
millennion twist to this ancient recipe
where I add a special ingredient such
that the Dragons will become instantly
crispy and once you put it into your
mouth you are able to breathe out white
smoke that many people call it the
dragon's breath without anybody starts
eating my cousin auntie Lily from this
trip I decided to take on the role to
continue making this dragon beard
readily available for one and all here
in Singapore I've loved to eat candies
since I was young and it has been a
simple pleasure for me in the forests of
Southeast Asia high up in the treetops a
mythical creature lives it turns out
dragons are real
so I have to call a biologist I'm
Anthony Russell from the Department of
Biological Sciences at the University of
Calgary in Alberta Canada we're talking
about a species of flying lizards so
it's called Draco Volans which means
flying dragon
okay these flying dragons they are a
little different from the dragons we see
in movies first starters they're small
but yeah they are only about eight
inches long and they don't breathe fire
but they do fly in a way they're gliders
which means they have control of their
descent and trajectory but they don't
have any power in it for every one foot
they go down in vertical distance
they'll be able to travel six feet alone
that's because they don't actually have
wings they're actually modifications of
the ribs so they're nothing to do with
the legs and arms evolutionarily
speaking this has helped the lizards
survive they can escape attacks and they
have a broader living zone so they might
not be dragon dragons
sometimes people main things because
it's more dramatic effect well they're
still incredible lizards actually no you
know what I'm still gonna call them
dragons
[Music]